él es federico gutiérrez pero prefiere
que lo llamen fico el ingeniero civil de
47 años es el más joven de los
candidatos presidenciales inició su
carrera política siendo consejero
municipal de su ciudad natal medellín
luego fue concejal de la capital de
antioquia entre los años 2004 y 2011 su
cargo más representativo fue como
alcalde de medellín entre el 2016 y 2019
es la primera vez que fico busca llegar
a la presidencia y según las encuestas
es el segundo favorito yo soy un
colombiano común y corriente como
ustedes que tienen vocación de servicio
por colombia y que así como me ven hoy
este es el pico que van a ver siempre
que me gusta es ponerme unos botines
unos tenis
rico viene del sector conservador y
privilegia la mano dura en temas de
seguridad oponiéndose por ejemplo a
negociar con los grupos armados también
ha cuestionado el reciente fallo de la
corte constitucional colombiana que
despenaliza el aborto hasta la semana 24
del embarazo sus propuestas se centran
en mejorar la calidad de vida de los
colombianos luchar contra la corrupción
y se ha fijado una meta bastante
ambiciosa para trabajar a sacar a la
gente de la pobreza no a tener más gente
en la pobreza que es lo que terminaría
pasando con ellos en términos económicos
fico plantea alcanzar un crecimiento del
5 por ciento del pib hasta el 2026 para
alcanzar sus metas ha indicado que es
importante el apoyo al sector privado
del país cuidar las empresas vamos a
cuidar a nuestros empresarios
en medio de una colombia convulsa donde
el hartazgo por parte de un sector
grande de los ciudadanos se ha
manifestado durante los últimos años de
gestión del presidente saliente iván
duque las críticas alrededor de la
campaña de fisco se fundamentan en que
este candidato supondría la continuidad
del gobierno